one thing that's really popular among
Republicans right now is to take
positions and support policy ideas that
are really common to parts of the world
that we often don't aspire to be like by
we I mean these very Republicans don't
and also that are playing Coy with the
ideas and policies of extreme dictators
and authoritarians and the latest idea
is that Donald Trump has been on a kick
about executing drug dealers putting
drug dealers to death Trump has now
started fundraising off of this idea he
talks about it regularly at his rallies
so let's start there here's just one
example Trump has seized on this because
I guess some in the crowd seem to kind
of like it they kill 500 people during a
lifetime and I think it's much worse
than that I think that's only what we
hear about
it would stop it I I if you didn't get
it down 75 80 90 from day one I'd be
surprised and these committees that they
set up it's laughable it's a horrible
thing we would solve that problem so
fast and I'm calling on Republicans and
Democrats immediately to Institute to
get to Washington and Institute the
death penalty for drug dealers you will
no longer have a problem there it is
kill the drug dealers and as you all
probably know by now from years of
following this guy when he seizes on
something he really seizes on it and of
course the ideal thing would be can I
make some money off of it and indeed
Donald Trump is now sending out
fundraising emails about this Donald J
trump.com sent out an email called the
death penalty and when you look inside
the email it's another one of these fake
polls and what I mean by that is it
looks like a poll they want you to take
a survey but it's actually a fundraising
pitch do you agree that drug dealers
should face the death penalty yes or no
thank you team Trump take the survey now
you know capital punishment for drug
trafficking is something that some
countries do have now it's rarely
because you got caught selling some pot
on the street but there are countries
that have extremely severe punishments
for drug dealing and drug trafficking
but I'm going to tell you what some of
those countries are
and they are typically countries that
Republicans say are backwards this is
what they say Republicans say these are
backwards countries that the U.S should
not be trying to be like these are the
countries that have the death penalty
capital punishment for drug trafficking
they include Bahrain and Bangladesh
Egypt Iran and Iraq Jordan Kuwait Libya
North Korea Qatar Pakistan Syria you get
the idea these are not exactly countries
that Republicans say should be The
Guiding Light for how the United States
should operate and the the sort of I
don't know that I want to call it funny
the sad thing to some degree is that
many of the ideas that Republicans like
are only seen in these authoritarian
type countries often Muslim
authoritarian countries you know when
right-wingers uh uh sort of art
titillated by this idea of uh Christian
nationalism a Christian version of
sharia law and a total melding of their
religion and civil government
the countries that are like that tend to
be countries Republicans don't like
right I mean it's it's Saudi Arabia it's
Iran it's you get the picture and so
when you say to Republicans the models
for what you're talking about are these
countries they have well no no no no
those countries are no good but here it
would be good if we did it but it's
because this is this would be with
Christianity that we would do it they're
doing it with Islam shockingly more and
more Republican ideas sound like the
ideas of these authoritarian dictatorial
countries and now Donald Trump has
seized on let's kill drug dealers and by
the way
this idea of every drug dealer kills 500
people it's absurd it's truly absurd
nobody has been able to actually find
any evidence backing that up and now
Donald Trump is trying to fundraise off
of it I often have a very hectic
schedule and I don't always have the
time to plan the exact nutrition of all
of my meals but our sponsor athletic
greens just makes it easy to make sure
I'm getting the nutrients I want I've
been using it for almost a year now and
it's great ag1 by athletic greens is a
delicious plant-based blend of 75 high
quality vitamins minerals and probiotics
from whole food sources if I have just
one small scoop of ag1 a day I know I'm
getting the nutrition and nutrients that
I want that support all of the things
that are important to me the only
alternative would be to take 20
different vitamin pills and things every
day I'm not doing that I don't want to
do that ag1 is super tasty you can put
it in a smoothie I drink it straight I
just like the veggie taste of it
achieving good nutrition and feeling
your best does not have to be
complicated you can make AG one part of
your daily routine in the way I have
done when you go to athleticgreens.com
Pacman you will get a one-year supply of
vitamin D and five free travel packs the
link is down below